Quando a mãe tá dormindo é o momento
mais sagrado da terra o caba faz tudo em
câmera
lenta se chegar a visita ei mãe mãezinha
mãezinha linda do meu coração te amo
para sempre desculpa estar te acordando
chegou uma visita aqui e não importa não
meso pode ser a polícia
federal Senor é H da Polícia Federal a
gente tem um mandado de prisão contra Tu
é doido desgraça fala baixo olha me
respeite viu que eu sou uma autoridade
ih Respeita respeita deixa a mãe acordar
que ela fica com raiva ela desconta em
mim depois Eita tua mãe é igual a minim
ó chama lá ela lá ver se ela se ela me
atende aqui as políci aqui ei mãe
mãezinha estão uns policial bem na porta
é o maior cuidado do mundo meu amigo
agora quando é nós que estamos dormindo
é tá nem aí meu amigo 7 hor da manhã meu
amigo Bora levantar que você não tem
empregada PR est arrumando as coisas PR
você mexer não he